people do waste a lot of time and
they're they also act
counterproductively a lot of the time
regardless we do make progress you are
where you are right now in your life and
your business because of you you're
actually tougher than you think
you never knew that
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
believe nation i am not a morning person
but when you start your day with a
powerful routine that inspires you like
watching one of these videos it will
change your life so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee know
that i believe in you and get ready for
a shot of espresso from jordan peterson
[Music]
in any case people do waste a lot of
time and they are they also act
counterproductively a lot of the time
regardless we do make progress and and
and and we can
thrive
under the difficult conditions that make
up our lives and we can resist the
malevolence that entices us that's
within our power
and we don't know the limits to that and
we also know that
it's better
to
we all know this
that it's better
to live
courageously
than cowardly
everyone knows that that's what you
teach people that you love
and and
and we know that it's better to live
truthfully than in deceit
and you can tell that too because that's
also what you tell people that you love
and we know that
you should
pick up your damn responsibility
and move forward everyone knows that
it's it's part of our intrinsic
moral
nature
and that nature is there and it's not
difficult to communicate to people about
this like
everyone knows
that you wake up at three in the morning
when you've left let your life go off
the rails and that you berate yourself
for your uselessness and your cruelty
and your failure to take off
to take the opportunities that are in
front of you and if you were the master
in your own house in some sense
the captain of your own destiny if there
was no intrinsic nature well that would
never happen you'd just let yourself off
the hook there'd be no voice of
conscience tormenting you
but no one escapes from that and what
that indicates to me is that at least
psychologically
we live in a universe that's
characterized by a moral dimension and
we understand that well and that moral
failings have consequences and that
they're not trivial they destroy you
they destroy your family they destroy
your community and and
you can tell people that
and they listen because they know
they don't know they know
that's the thing and maybe that's the
thing about being an
intellectual you have the opportunity to
articulate
ideas that other people know they embody
but they can't articulate and that's
what people tell me you know they say
well
you help me
give words to things that i always knew
to be true but couldn't say
or
or they say i've been trying to put some
of your precepts into practice
responsibility being a main one vision
another honesty i i suppose bringing up
the pack and saying this is the fun part
of doing all of this
fun is a weak word that it's it's it's a
it's the remarkable part of doing all
this i mean i have people tell me
constantly wherever i go
it's so delightful that
you know they're in a pretty dark place
and they tell me why and there's plenty
of dark places in the world and they
decided well
maybe they were going to develop a bit
of a vision and take a bit more
responsibility and start telling the
truth and putting some effort into
something and they come up and they say
well you can't believe how much better
things are you are where you are right
now in your life and your business
because of you because of your mindset
your actions your habits your beliefs
your where you're at
because of you it's nobody else's fault
you're not further behind
you're not
you're not
lower than you used to be you're not
further behind on your goals but you're
also not further ahead you're not where
you want to be and it's because of you
it's not it's not the government's fault
it's not the tax
tax policy fault it's not your country's
fault it's not your parent's fault your
education's fault it's your friend's
fault it's none of those things it's you
it's you it's you it's you it's you it's
you it's you it's you it's you and
listen at the beginning that sounds like
a lot of
tough medicine it's like well if it's
not my fault i mean
sure it's my fault but come on look at
what happened covet happened you know
all this other stuff happened and it's
easy to to put the blame on something
else
but when you can actually
realize that you are where you are
because of you
it's it's not just a tough love it's
actually the most empowering thing of
all time
because
when you take the responsibility it
doesn't mean that's your fault
it doesn't mean that you can change
anything that you've done in the past
but it's your responsibility
to get to a different place it's not
about assigning blame
it's about taking responsibility which
is the ability to respond right
responsibility equals the ability
to respond do you have an ability to
respond yes when always
covet happened great do you have an
ability to respond yes what are you
doing about it
and while most people are upset and
complaining and waiting for the
government to do something
you're off responding you're off making
a change you're off making a difference
making a pivot making new things happen
that's what separates successful people
from everybody else and i want that for
you
so it recognizes that okay here here i'm
stuck here this is where i am right now
i don't want to stay stuck here
i want to change i want to grow i've got
a big mission that i have to go off and
accomplish how do you do that you change
your mindset you change your beliefs you
change your habits and it starts with
you accepting responsibility for where
you're at
i've got you know my main channel three
million subscribers i'm not a 10. i'm
not at one i'm not at i'm not at 50
subscribers
and so the point isn't beat ourselves up
i'm i'm grateful for everything that
i've done i'll own the fact that hey i
i got us to building an organization a
team a structure uh making 10 000 videos
to now you know i've got 3 million
subscribers amazing great pat on the
back and i'm not a 10.
i'm not a 10 because i need to get
better the videos need to get better the
team needs to get better the strategy
needs to get better the productions to
get better everything needs to get
better for me to get to where i want to
go
it's easy for me to say well nobody's
done
that inside of thought leadership
nobody's done it before
nobody's
nobody has a 10 million subscriber
channel inside of thought leadership
nobody i could say people don't care
about education that much i could say
well i don't have as many resources as
somebody who's further ahead or part of
some giant corporation i don't i don't
have as many resources i could say well
i'm i'm introverted and shy and you know
so i can't i can't be great you know
there's a there's a ceiling to how good
i can be
right and these are the kinds of
thinking that are fear-based
that keep you small because we don't
want to accept the responsibility
because the responsibility feels like
blame
and that's where you have to separate
it's not about blame it's not saying
that you suck it's not saying you should
have done something different it's not
beating ourselves up
it's the ability to respond
i'm not trying to blame anything for
where i'm at and i hope you're not
blaming yourself or anybody around you
for where you're at
but it's taken on the ability to say you
know what i i don't want to end up in
the same spot if i'm a year from now and
i'm still at x right
then i'm gonna be upset
because i i can't change
you can't change
so how do we do it how do we start to
develop that
that sense of responsibility how do we
start to actually take the action we
need to take action on a couple things
one
change your environment
if you're surrounded by people by
thinking where it's constantly
complaining especially blaming like
watch out for people who blame
watch out for people who say well it's
that person's fault it's their fault
it's it's this person's fault it's their
fault over there and never accepting any
responsibility or they're just
constantly trying to blame other people
right watch out for those people don't
be infected by their cancer that's a
cancer
that person is never going to be happy
you need to really dramatically reduce
the amount of time that you're spending
with those kinds of people and then
inject it with more of the positivity
more of the optimism more of the
responsibility whatever you want more of
in your life if it's accepting
responsibility surround yourself with
the people who are doing it surround
yourself with the people who have that
mindset either in in person or through
videos like this
you know you i may never meet you but
you can learn from this i you may never
meet jordan peterson but you can learn
from this video right you can learn from
their content their videos their books
their podcasts so it's an immediate
change in your environment because you
are a product of your environment your
environment impacts your subconscious
you're not even consciously knowing but
if you're around people who are blaming
other people all the time you're gonna
just by default start to blame other
people start to complain a lot of the
time
you'll have to consciously make the
shift to say i don't want to be this
person why am i complaining so much why
am i so negative and nasty why am i
blaming other people so much
look at your environment
that's the reason why
right so
we're cutting out or restricting access
to the people who are in that blaming
complaining mode and we're injecting
positivity in through humans through
videos books podcasts etc right step
number one change your environment
step number two
is recognize the situation for what it
is
no worse than it is
but no better than it is
what is the situation right now so if
i'm looking at my my main youtube
channel and i'm trying to grow it okay
where am i at i'm at 3 million
subscribers great it's no worse than it
is it's not like oh i suck and i don't
know what to do and i'm not grateful for
anything that we've built
it's looking at what do i have i've i've
got this channel i've got some amazing
you know people in the community i've
got an amazing team of people who help
me
it's great for where i'm at
it's no worse than it is we tend to beat
ourselves up and feel like we're further
behind but it's also no better than it
is it's not where i want to be yet and
we're still not good enough at anything
we're not good enough at production that
thumbnails the titles and editing at me
being on camera like we're not good at
we're not good enough at any of the
stuff none of it right it's where we
need to be so
you're changing your environment step
number one to have a more optimistic
more positive more energetic more happy
environment around us
two we're then looking at the situation
for what is the truth of it no worse
than it is
but no better than it is
when it's worse we we pound on ourselves
and tell ourselves we suck when it's
better we feel like we don't have to
change because everything is great right
so no worse than it is no better and
then three is what are your actual steps
what are you gonna do what's the plan of
action
when you can look at the truth of the
situation
what needs to actually improve
how do you actually start making
progress towards your goals
what are the habits routines mindset
belief shifts that you need to make
on a daily basis like what does today
now look like not just in in theory of i
need to believe in myself more awesome
yes i love it that's changing your
environment how does that apply to today
like what are you going to do today
that's different than what you did
yesterday what are you going to do this
week that's different than what you did
last week what's the new plan what's the
new plan that you're gonna execute on
every single day to move closer to
actually accomplishing your goals
and if you can follow that process you
can follow those steps and it's a it's a
continuous loop
right you're never done on any of it
you're never done you're always trying
to improve your environment
always you're always trying to prove in
your environment you're always trying to
see the world for what it is right now
see your situation for what it is right
now i know you're always trying to
create a plan to then actually execute
to help you get closer to your goals
always
and and that's not hopefully stressful
to you because you always want to be
growing you always want to be learning
you always want to be improving the day
the progress stops the day you stop
liking your life if there was no
progress no growth no change you
wouldn't like your life you'd be bored
go get a job that's that's what most
people do and most people don't like
their life because they're in a really
really boring job
right so you you have these steps on
loop on repeat and that's how you start
getting closer to becoming the person
you want to be and achieving the goals
that you want
at the start of all this though is still
the
accepting responsibility
responsibility does not equal blame
you are where you are because of you
because of the choices that you made
because of the beliefs that you have
because the actions that you have taken
you are where you are because of those
actions and that's gotten you so far
and if you want to change you want to
grow you want to improve you want to hit
your mission you want to get closer to
hitting your goals
you now have to take responsibility for
the person you need to become to
actually make those dreams a reality now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
what is your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated you get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
actually doing something following
through that believe nation is not
enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this and then you create a
plan of action your chances of following
through jump to 911
and when you commit publicly like
putting your comment down below with
your plan it jumps to 95 that's what i
want for you i want you to take action
your dreams are too important your life
matters your mission has to happen so
question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
celebrate alongside with you also if you
want to have more confident self love
self belief check out my 254 series the
sign says it can take up to 254 days of
consecutive action to build a habit so
i've designed a special free program to
help you get it where i will send you an
unlisted video to your email for the
next 254 days to shift your self-belief
forward the link to sign up for free is
in the description below if you're going
to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about well you have to treat
yourself like you matter because if you
don't then you don't take care of
yourself and you become vengeful oh no
you're okay you should feel good about
yourself like you're you're fine the way
you are it's like you think well that's
a calming message for people make a damn
schedule and stick to it okay so what's
the rule with the schedule it's not a
bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong they say well i don't like to have
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
i have to do this then i have to do this
then i have to do this you know and then
i just go play video games because who
wants to do all these things that i have
to do it's like wrong
set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking
what would it look like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that than at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy so maybe 20
of your day has to be responsibility and
obligation or maybe it's more than that
depending on how far behind you are but
even that you can you can ask yourself
okay well i've got these
responsibilities i have to schedule the
damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward and you can ask yourself that
just like you'd negotiate with someone
who is working for you it's like okay
you got to work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70 accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
the next week or 50 and a half percent
for god's sake or because you're you're
going to hit that position where things
start to loop back positively and spiral
you upward you don't have to necessarily
have done anything wrong for things to
get completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way forward
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a mode of
being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone who's capable of
standing up in the face of that terrible
vulnerability and suffering and that the
pathway forward as far as the
existentialists are concerned is by well
certainly by the avoidance of deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of responsibility for the
conditions of existence and some attempt
on your part to actually rectify them
and the thing that's so interesting
about that is that well two as far as
i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over
decades-long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were if they
said
if they spoke their being forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something i mean you can think
about this yourselves i often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done that's probably four hours right
there
you know you think well that's 20 25
hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting 50
000 a year is a way bigger catastrophe
than it would be for me to waste it
because i'm not going to last nearly as
long and so if your life isn't
everything it could be you could ask
yourself well what would happen if you
just stopped wasting the opportunities
that are in front of you
you'd be
who knows how much more efficient 10
times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment
both of which are are are are major
causes of suffering and the failure of
individuals to adopt the responsibility
that they know they should adopt and
this is why i wanted to introduce social
nissan's readings to you you see because
it isn't merely that your fate depends
on whether or not you get your act
together and to what degree you decide
that you're going to live out your own
genuine being it isn't only your fate
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with and so you know you think
well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to peak
at about 9 billion by the way and then
it'll decline rapidly but 7 billion
people in the world and who are you
you're just one little dust moat among
that 7 billion and so it really doesn't
matter what you do or don't do but
that's simply not the case it's the
wrong model because you're at the center
of a network you're a node in a network
of course that's even more true now that
we have social media you'll you'll know
a thousand people at least over the
course of your life and they'll know a
thousand people each and that puts you
one person away from a million and two
persons away from a billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but i mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice i can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price i pay is that nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are
when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well what
solzhenitsyn figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that
if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century the next best predictor of
lifetime success is conscientiousness
well so and of the of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
and industriousness the better predictor
is industriousness so the question is
well what can you do about your
industriousness and the answer to that
is
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with this future authoring
program processes i think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to set up some aims
for yourself goals that you actually
value
and the future authoring program helps
people do that
and basically it does a situational
analysis of it helps you do a
situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis i would
say and so the questions are something
like well
all right you're gonna have to put some
effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high in neuroticism you want security
okay so those are all sources of
potential motivation that you could draw
on that you could tailor to your own you
know your own personality but then there
are dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about
well you know if you could have your
life the way you wanted it in three to
five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to augur down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control and
then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates
the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down the goal into
micro processes that you can implement
the micro processes become rewarding in
proportion
in relation to their uh causal
association with the goal and that
tangles in your your incentive reward
system you know we talked about the
dopaminergic incentive reward system and
that's the thing that keeps you moving
forward and the way it works is that it
works better
if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal
you do that
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual you want you want to specify
goals that make you say oh if that could
happen as a consequence of my efforts it
would clearly be worthwhile because the
question always is why do something
because doing nothing is easy you just
sit there and you don't do anything
that's real easy the question is why
would you ever do anything and the
answer that has to be because you've
determined by some
means that it's worthwhile and then the
next question might be well where should
you look for worthwhile things and one
would be well you could consult your own
temperament and the other would be well
you kind of look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the sub components of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
so
so once but once you set up that that
goal structure let's say and that's
really in many in many ways that's what
you should be doing at universities is
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you you aim at that and then
use everything you learn as a means of
building that person that you want to be
and and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap and it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so if
i was saying well you're going to try to
make yourself more industrious okay
number one specify your damn goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure so if you keep
yourself all vague and foggy which is
real easy because that's just a matter
of not doing as well then you don't know
when you fail
and people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful so i'll keep myself blind about
when i fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done and that can easily
happen by the time you're 40.
so so
i would recommend that you don't let
that happen so that's willful blindness
right you could have known but you chose
not to okay so once you get your goal
structure set up you think okay if i
could have this life it looks like that
might be worth living despite the fact
that it's going to be you know
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that obviously
the goal is to to have a vision for your
life such that all things considered
that justifies your effort i started to
pay very careful attention to
what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
i split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot
and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas and
there was another part that was watching
that part like just with its eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that
you don't really know what you're
talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people
have multiple parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like
well which of those two things are me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's rubbish that's a lie
that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i'd
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then
they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as a coherence between the
the
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen
i know you stated in the last um
uh lecture that the importance for
setting aims in life and um
to kind of have goals to uh work towards
right so my question was um
where do you how do you do that if you
don't know where you want to go because
that's kind of where i got stuck on your
your future authoring program because
okay that's that's a good question
that's a really good question so there's
this notion in the old testament that
morality is
following a sequence of prohibitions
there's a bunch of bad things you
shouldn't do and then basically you're
good enough
and and and i think there's wisdom in
that i i think that's kind of where
children start right you
i mean i love children and all that but
they're they're they're crazy little
creatures and they need to be you know
civilized and partly what you do is you
you lay prohibitions on them and mostly
what you're trying to do is lay
prohibitions on them
for the behaviors that if they
manifested would make their life
miserable so this is why this thing that
i've said to people has become this
crazy internet meme but that's to clean
up your room and
which which is a lot better and more
useful than people think it's a lot
harder too but the the thing the first
thing you do i think and i learned this
in part from solzhenitsyn when he was
trying to iron out his soul when he was
in the gulag because he was trying to
figure out how he got there how he
contributed to how he got there you know
not stalin and hitler even though they
were kind of to blame you know but
he was much he could do about that i
think what you have to do and this is
part of humility is you have to look
around you within your sphere of
influence like the direct sphere of
influence and fix the things that
announce themselves as in need of repair
and those are often small things you
know and they can be like
your room put it in order because the
thing is it isn't exactly so important
that your room is in order although it
is what's important is that you learn
how to distinguish between chaos and
order and to be able to act in a manner
that produces order and i think you can
you can do something as simple as just
sit on your bed and think okay there's
probably like five things i could do
today so that
tomorrow morning is slightly better than
this morning was at least or at least
i'm not falling behind and those will
usually be it's like having to eat a
toad in the morning right it's like it's
not going to be something you want to do
there'll be things you're trying to
avoid they're snakes essentially but if
you ask yourself like you're asking
someone which i think is a form of
prayer if you ask yourself instead of
telling yourself you know what is it
that i could do to set things more right
today
that i would actually do
it's usually some small thing because
you're not that disciplined you know
then you can go do it and then you you
put the world together a little more
when you do that
and that spreads out but you also put
your you also construct yourself into
something that's better able to call
order forth from chaos and that makes
you just incrementally stronger and then
the next day you can maybe take on a
slightly larger task and like you get
the benefit of compound interest if you
do that it's a tremendously powerful
technique and i think if you do that
at some point
instead of just having to fix things up
that are not good you'll start to get a
glimmer of the positive things that you
could do
you know
the positive things that you could do
that would actually constitute a vision
and that that's what i would recommend
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
overprotected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity
you know so maybe you're a kid in the
playground right and you're having some
trouble with other kids and you know in
the back of your mind i should deal this
with deal with this myself but you go
and tell your mom and get her to
intervene and you know that that's not
right you know that you're breaking the
social contract but it's easier and so
that's what you do you run off to an
authority figure and hide behind the
great father right roughly speaking well
the problem with that is you don't learn
how to do it yourself so then you have
to relearn it painfully when you're 40.
so then you take people out
you say well what are you afraid of rank
it from 1 to 10.
so 10 is
make a list of 10 things you're afraid
of the least the thing you're least
afraid of we'll call number 10.
so we'll start with that okay well i'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death open because that's how
you're responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest
proximity you can manage
you find out you go do that it works
you're nervous as hell especially
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
10 times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned
and then you move a little closer and
then you move a little closer and then
you move a little closer and finally
you're back in what's no longer the
elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
turns out i can withstand that and then
you're met much more
together much more confident
and that's often one of the things that
often happens in situations like that
i've seen this multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up they'll often start
standing up to people around them in a
way they never did before
i had a plumber once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and he had put in
all the plastic piping you know and i
was going to test the joints they're
supposed to be glued together with this
pipe glue right and i said i told him i
had to test the joints and he said well
you don't have to test my joints they
never leak and i thought yeah that's
okay how about if i test them so i went
up on the third floor and filled the
pipes with water capping them in the
basement like you're supposed to and
like half an hour later i had two inches
of water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so
well so he wasn't particularly competent
that's the point of that story but even
more so he had put a bunch of the
plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a tradesperson it's a bloody reliable
honorable uh forthright productive way
of making a living and there is a hell
of a lot of difference between a working
man who knows what he's doing and one
who doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
pleasure they tell you what they're
going to do they tell you how much it
will cost they go and do it it works and
you pay them perfect everyone's happy
and that's what happens when you have
genuine hierarchies of competence and so
you listen to these panderers of
egalitarianism
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people it's
not such a terrible thing man maybe you
wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible most people aren't
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one
go try in another but the point is
you're still trying to aim for the top
and what are you gonna do if you don't
try to aim for the top you know flap
about uselessly and whine about your
life it's not helpful it'll just make
you miserable you're not reliable to
anyone you can't help out in a crisis
it's like so you tell young people and
this is another message for
conservatives like i don't care what
you're going to do but go out there make
something of yourself for god's sake be
an honest person and work and get to the
top of whatever it is that you want to
get to the top of you know and and and
and that stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a
world beater they think really that's
possible wow that would be that would be
interesting that might make life for
life worth living it's like yeah it
might so why don't you go do it that's
what the damn universities were supposed
to be teaching people they've forgotten
that i went to harvard a month ago month
and a half i used to teach there and i
talked to a bunch of students you know
and i told them it's not easy to get
into harvard you know like you're a
valedictorian if you're at harvard and
not only are you a valedictorian you're
way better than most people at at least
two other things or you don't get in and
so like it's i don't know what the
acceptance rate is like five percent and
believe me not everybody applies so it's
a very selective school and so why am i
saying that it's like these are high
quality kids so i told them what i just
told you it's like here you are at
harvard it's like get yourself educated
man read some books learn to talk learn
to think make yourself into something
get out there and make the world that
put you here happy that you were put
there in that great institution you know
and they came up to me afterwards and
said god i wish someone would have told
us that when we were in our first year
it's like jesus why didn't someone tell
them that for god's sake it's supposed
to be the greatest university in the
world is it so difficult to figure that
out i like this one and i think i mean
this is very clearly what you do be
precise in your speech
so in in genesis one of the things god
has adam do first so god makes the world
by speaking okay so that's the first
thing to think about
you're supposed to think like
in a sophisticated way about this the
idea is that there's some integral
relationship between
communication and the structure of being
it's part of the role that consciousness
plays in the world whatever that role is
language
takes the chaos and makes it into things
and so god has adam name all the animals
they're not even really real until they
have names
now
they're more implicit that's another you
know here's a here's an example let's
say that
you're having a rough patch in your
relationship
and you don't know why it's unnameable
is it real well yeah it's manifesting
itself in a like a physiological
discomfort
then you talk about it and you name it
it's like it goes from this blurry thing
that's kind of potential it goes snap
and then it's this thing
right and then that's a horrible thing
it's like a little poisonous thing but
it's not a whole
foggy cloud of potential poison it's
like this little sharp poison thing and
then you think okay
it's real it's a little monster but it's
not it's little at least and now
probably we can do something about it if
we can admit to it so it's this
precision that specifies and like so
this is a little bit of the voldemort
effect right if since you're a harry
potter guy they wouldn't name it right
this is a problem we got to name them
first oh yeah you got to name them first
absolutely because the unnamable is far
more terrifying than the name-able
you see that in there was this great
blair witch project terrifying movie
really yeah well it's unnamed
there's nothing terrible happens in that
movie it's all the unnamable it's like
what's going on what's going on what's
going on and
no matter how terrible the actuality is
it's rarely as terrible as your
imagination because your imagination
like it's an old thing it's seen a lot
of terrible things in the history of
life like it can put monsters everywhere
and so it's almost always better
it might be better without exception to
name the thing no matter how terrible it
is and if you can't name it what that
means is that you're you're telling
yourself that you're so terrified that
you can't bring your attention to bear
on it and that makes you
you're the loser instantly if it's so
terrifying that you cannot face it
2016 that i wouldn't speak the language
of the radical leftists because i don't
think that that language should define
the game but let's say it does so here's
the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game
and some of them win and they oppress
those who don't win so that's how we're
going to view the world
okay now the left is say okay well
here's the oppressed people the
oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves and
give up some power
the right wingers the radical
right-wingers look at that and they say
oh i see so the game is ethnic identity
is it it's it's identity politics okay
we're white males
we're not going to lose
that's the right wing version of
identity politics it's like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and i'm in my tribe
i'm not going to get all guilty and lose
i'm going to get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics spectrum
am i going to fall in do i want to go
with uh do i want to
go
do i want to be driven primarily by
compassion and
am i going to accept guilt for my
historical privilege so that's one
possibility and then i'm the oppressor
i'm the member of the oppressor group or
am i going to say oh no with that i'm
just going to play to win well then i'm
going to go to the right it's like well
my sense is how about we don't play
either of those games and the reason we
shouldn't play them is
well the soviets played the left wing
game and like killed
who knows how many tens of millions of
people you can't even count it
accurately the estimates range from 20
to 100 million those are pretty big
error bars and the maoists maybe a
hundred million certainly 60 million
so okay that didn't work out so well and
then there's the nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like what do we want to
play that game
see what i've been trying to do really
what i've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look
there's heavy temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together
stand up in the world make something of
yourself stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications
set your house in order that's rule six
in the in the in this book so i have a
book rule in there says set your house
in perfect order before you criticize
the world and it's a
very dark chapter about the motivations
of the columbine high school killers and
this other guy named carl panzram who
was a serial rapist and arsonist and
murderer and these he wrote an
autobiography and the columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful
terrible
and
well i'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah you can you can tell a
story where everyone's a victim
because we all die we all get sick
you know and and and things happen to us
that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people hurt us on purpose you know
so it's not just the tragedy of life
it's malevolence as well it's everyone's
a victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story and
you start to act it out you make all of
that worse that's the problem
and it's so this is why partly i got
attracted to christian imagery at least
in part
um because there's an idea in
christianity that you should pick up
your goddamn cross and like walk up the
hill
and that's
dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust so what are you going to do about
it accept it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence
that's the right answer it's the right
answer because the rest of it is
tribalism and
we're we're too technologically powerful
to get all tribal again the more radical
the necessary change the more pain that
accompanies it like the more opportunity
as well
but and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully and so it's not surprising
that people shrink away from learning we
learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man like it took you out
and so the fact that people flee from
that is hardly surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better
the better
idea is to eat a little poison every day
so that you don't have to overdose in a
month it's something like that
and it is the case that i think because
you don't you aren't forced first of all
you don't learn unless you're forced to
learn i know there's alternatives to
that there's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote to this but
apart from that
speaking more
practically
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force are difficult
lessons
and so people are very prone to not
did not seek that out
it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you
it's because maybe it's because they're
convinced that there's some way of
forestalling the necessary learning
and there isn't
any way of forestalling it all you do is
make it worse in the future you make
yourself smaller and you make the lesson
harder
and so that's why in so many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility
you know and humility isn't to debase
yourself
it's to understand that
you don't know enough so that your life
isn't going to be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way you should take it as fast as
you can
but you have to have a very
tragic
i would say view of reality and also a
harsh one because it's not just tragedy
it's also malevolence you have to
understand that those are waiting for
you and
that makes you desperate enough to learn
and that might be make you desperate
enough to fall out of your ideology
but
that's that's a hard way of looking at
the world
it beats living through it though your
best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right i mean sometimes you go fight a
dragon and it eats you
and if the
if you being eaten wasn't a real
possibility
it wouldn't be a real fight
and so you see people like i've seen
people in my clinical practice sometimes
i had one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who was really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything at her
disposal to do so
and i strategized with him for about
three years
and we did everything like and hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he
put into practice everything that we
discussed and strategized and he still
pretty much he got backed into a corner
so hard that i didn't know how to help
him anymore
so
i would say however that he like he was
a very truthful person throughout that
and one thing he did do was
part of it was a custody battle
and he did
manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered i would say he did manage to
establish what i think was a lasting
relationship with his kids
so he might have got
enough out of what he did to justify it
even though
the whole landscape was pretty
awful
i think that
not lying is your best bet
but
life is hard and people get run over and
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to emerge in any obvious sense
triumphant
but if you take the alternative path
path especially when you're
facing severe tribulations let's say and
you complicate those with deceit you can
be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to hell
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't
overcome it or transcend it
and that's something yes this
circumambulation that jung talked about
was this
continual
will return to this this continual
circling in some sense of who you could
be you might notice for example that
there are themes in your life you know
when you go back across your experiences
you see you kind of have your typical
experience that sort of repeats itself
and there might be variation on it like
a musical theme but it's it's like
you're circling yourself and getting
closer to yourself as you move across
time that's the circumambulation now you
remember that for a second we'll go back
to it okay so imagine that something
glimmers before you it's an interest
that's dawning and you decide well first
of all you're paralyzed you think well
how do i know if i should pursue that
it's probably a stupid idea and the
proper response to that is you're right
it probably is a stupid idea because
almost all ideas are stupid
and so the the probability that as you
move forward on your adventure that
you're gonna get it right the first time
is zero it's just not gonna happen and
so then you might think well maybe i'll
just wait around until i get the right
idea and which people do right so
they're like 40 year old 13 year olds
which is not a good idea so they wait
around until it's waiting for godot
until they finally got it right but the
problem is you're too stupid to know
when you've got it right so waiting
around isn't going to help because even
if it the perfect opportunity manifested
itself to you in your incomplete form
the probability that you would recognize
it as the perfect opportunity is zero
you might even think it's the worst
possible idea that you've ever heard of
anywhere highly likely highly likely so
so you have there's
nietzsche called that a will will to
stupidity which i really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it
you know it's it's you have to take it
into account fundamentally and work with
it and so
and so you can take these tentative
steps
on your
pathway to destiny and you can assume
that you're going to do it badly and
that's really useful because you don't
have to beat yourself up it's pretty
easy to do it badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all you
start your path and you think that
you're heading you know towards your
star
and so you go in that direction and
then
because
you're here the world looks a particular
way but then when you move here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were
it's it's going to reveal itself with
more accuracy to you and so then you
have to take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal but it isn't because you know
you've
i mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far
but that's a lot farther than you would
be if you just stayed where you were
waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot
continually
because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn what you shouldn't keep doing
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing then
that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing
so it's okay
so it's like this
now what's cool about it though i think
is that as you progress the
degree of overshooting starts to decline
right and that we know that there's
nothing hypothetical about that as you
learn a new skill like even to play play
a song on the piano for example you
overshoot madly you're making all sorts
of mistakes to begin with and then the
mistakes
they they disappear so anyways
the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean you have to stop
and thank god for that that's a really
useful thing
and the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean that you can't learn
and so you can pause it an ideal and
you're going to be wrong about it but it
doesn't matter because what you're right
about is positing the ideal moving
towards it if the actual ideal isn't
conceptualize perfectly well first
surprise surprise because like what are
you gonna do that's perfect so
it doesn't matter that it's imperf
imperfect it just matters that you do it
and that you move forward so that's
really that's really positive news as
far as i'm concerned because you can
actually do that right you can do it
badly anyone can do that so that's
that's useful i'm incredibly nervous to
uh
talk in front of you because you've got
to be one of the most formidable people
that i've ever
heard of or ever listened to ever seen
so
my question is
again you're one of the best
communicators that i've ever listened to
if i could be
half as good
at you or at communicating as you are
i would be set how can i teach myself to
do that
practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things is
it helps to read
a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then
not only should you read but you should
write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day
15 minutes
maybe you could steal 15 minutes and do
it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at university because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
10 times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side
well there's some tricks
techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a packaged thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when i talk to a
group i always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier too
because you know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating but there isn't a
thousand people there
there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell
if they're engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so
one thing is to to have something to say
yeah but the next thing is pay attention
to who you're talking to
because unless you're very badly
socialized and that seems unlikely in
your case because you know you present
yourself at least moderately well you
know
and
well i mean i don't know you very well
but in first but on first sight
you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience that's a really bad way of
thinking about it you're actually
engaged in a conversation with an
audience even if they're not
talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or
and you can you can pull all that in and
and and use it to govern
the level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so
the last thing i would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well i
could buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate i don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter i mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so
the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges i think
i don't know if they've forgotten if
they don't do a very good job of
marketing it's like what's the use of a
bachelor's degree in bachelor of arts
it's like well you can think
you can write
you can speak
you've read something
it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that i've
watched in my life who've been
spectacularly successful are
they have skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're six it doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're really good negotiator everybody
walks away from the negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice
if you want more inspiration morning
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it it's right there next to me go
click it there continue to believe and
i'll see you there